how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder of where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe
spider-man 3's production is set to
begin in only just a few months tom
holland just has to finish filming
uncharted and then he's on the set for
spider-man 3. then of course all of the
crazy leaks and details about the movie
will probably come out and they'll
probably come from tom holland himself
but pretty soon we should finally figure
out just what is going on in the life of
spider-man after his identity has been
revealed
but what are the future plans for
spider-man after spider-man 3.
well some recent rumors that have been
going around the past few months say
that sony and marvel are actually
preparing us for a venom vs spider-man
showdown now of course when you hear
that you freak out internally because
that's what everybody wants
which means it would be a very wise
decision for sony and
marvel to do and that could possibly be
what they're planning because a rumor
says that we're going to be seeing
spider-man in the post-credits scene for
venom 2.
and this will apparently go on to set up
the sinister 6 and
venom vs spider-man in a future film so
we'll break it down but first be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the marvel videos and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a doctor strange funko pop just
subscribe
like the video and leave a comment down
below to enter so the recent rumor says
that spider-man
will show up in the venom 2 post credit
scene and spoiler warning in case this
rumor actually does end up being true
and happening
but rumor has it that at the end of
venom 2 venom and eddie brock will have
defeated cletus cassidy and
carnage cletus will unfortunately be
killed but apparently carnage won't be
done for good
and apparently he will talk to venom in
this post credit scene and convince him
that he's not actually good
he's an evil being that needs to eat
other beings then they will apparently
see spider-man in the post-credits scene
and that's when they decide to go after
him and this will ultimately
lead to a venom vs spider-man showdown
now right now this
is just a rumor but we already have
confirmation from kevin feige the
president of marvel studios
saying that spider-man can indeed cross
over
into the other universe that sony has
the spumc
the sony pictures universe of marvel
characters
in fact he teased us that there could be
something very very big coming
after the news that spider-man is indeed
staying in the marvel cinematic universe
after the recent
sony disney spider-man scare marvel
studios as president and now
ceo of marvel in its entirety kevin
feige said this in particular
spider-man also happens to be the only
hero with the super power to cross
cinematic universes so as sony continues
to develop their own spidey verse
you never know what surprises the future
might hold this is actually a pretty big
deal that some people may have
overlooked a little bit
this is the marvel studios president
basically confirming that we are going
to see spider-man in the sony universe
and if we think about it of course this
makes perfect sense
sony is actually building up their own
team to take on spider-man and there's
plenty of proof for this
for one kevin feige said you never know
what surprises the future might hold
this is pretty much confirming
spider-man will jump over and then not
too long after this we got the trailer
for
morbius and in the trailer we got two
new
pieces of evidence that this is going to
happen we have a scene with spider-man
on the wall with the words murderer over
him and then we have michael keaton's
vulture from spider-man homecoming
talking to morbius in the trailer in
what looks to be
him trying to recruit morbius for
something and there's probably only one
thing that he could really be trying to
recruit a living vampire for
and that would be to help him take down
a certain spider that he couldn't do
himself
a certain superhero that foiled his
plans put him in jail and basically made
him a really bad father
that's probably something that you'd
want payback for but he knows that he
can't beat spider-man because he already
lost to him so he needs a team and
fortunately for him he already met the
first person of his team
while he was in jail he met scorpion and
i heard a rumor
you know who he is
[Music]
if i knew he was he'd already be dead
your family's here
now in this post-credit scene scorpion
says i heard a rumor that you know
who he is and surprisingly it doesn't
seem like tombs wants to give away peter
parker's identity because after all he
is just a kid still
but if you pay attention the guard says
tombs your family's here
and then he walks away and he goes to
see his family now this
probably won't end too well when you get
thrown in jail for doing illegal things
your wife and your daughter usually
don't look upon you too well
so what i predict is going to happen is
that he's going to meet with his family
and they're going to be
extremely disappointed with him and this
visit probably won't go too well his
wife may leave him and his daughter if
she is even there may
say that she's never going to come visit
him and this is going to spark his
revenge
after this he'll throw the fact that
peter parker is a teenager
out the window and that's when he'll
plot his revenge but we have to keep in
mind that spider-man far from home has
happened
after homecoming and before morbius
meaning that everybody now knows that
peter parker
is spider-man so scorpion will go back
and talk to adrian tombs about peter
parker being spider-man and that's when
they'll plot their revenge and form
their team
now this of course will be the sinister
six
but who will be the members well if this
rumor about the post credit scene of
venom 2
is true that means that venom and
carnage could be on this team
now the sinister 6 vs spider-man will be
different than venom
vs spider-man but it is possible that
sony and
marvel have plans for both sony actually
already came out and said
after the first venom film released that
they actually wanted tom holland
in the movie however at the time marvel
studios said no because they didn't want
people to confuse the universes
well that's kind of out the window now
since kevin feige said that spider-man
can cross over into different universes
and we saw spider-man in the morbius
trailer so that confusion
or fear of confusion is pretty much out
the window plus we know that disney and
sony made a new deal
and we don't exactly know all the fine
details but it's pretty much believed
that
sony and disney made a deal that said
spider-man and other
sony characters that appeared in the mcu
can cross over into their universe
so this gives sony pretty much exactly
what they wanted
spider-man in a venom film now venom 2
has already been filmed it's already
done
and we know that spider-man in the mcu
at least has one more solo film and then
a team-up film left on his contract but
that's all the details that we really
know
and as far as everybody is concerned
spider-man can jump over to the sp
umc anytime he wants and we know that
they're building a universe that
seemingly doesn't like spider-man we
know this from the photo of spider-man
in the morbius trailer that says
murderer over it so what is sony's and
marvel because as of right now they do
have a say in this
master plan well it's seemingly the
sinister 6 which has clearly been set up
in the mcu and in the sp umc and then
venom everyone wants to see the sinister
six take on spider-man but ultimately
they want to see spider-man vs venom and
sony
knows this and apparently it's what they
wanted since the very first venom film
and with kevin feige basically giving
the okay that spider-man can jump over
into that universe now
and telling us that we may be in for a
little bit of a surprise
in the future everything is pretty much
set up and laid out for us to eventually
get a spider-man
vs venom film and we may be in for a
reverse
comic situation in the comics venom
bonds with spider-man
and once the two of them separate venom
begins to hate spider-man because he
actually wants to re-bond with him but
spider-man won't have it so it's pretty
much a love-hate relationship
but of course if you've seen venom in
the sony universe we know that the first
earth host for venom is eddie brock and
this is much different from the comics
because in the comics when spider-man
gets away from venom
venom then goes to eddie so could we
possibly see the separation of venom and
eddie and then the bonding of spider-man
and venom in a future film
it seems like that's what sony wants to
be set up and when this happens perhaps
the venom
symbiote may enjoy peter parker a little
bit more than eddie brock and this could
create a lot of problems especially
between peter parker and
eddie brock who will no doubt at the
time love having the venom symbiote
and peter parker in the mcu being the
good kid that he is won't want the venom
symbiote and that's where that eddie
brock hate for peter parker could come
and that's where the venom hate for
peter parker could come as well
so undoubtedly sony has some pretty big
plans for spider-man in their own
universe
and apparently right now marvel studios
is okay with it
what would you think of a venom vs
spider-man film and what would you want
to see from it
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all the latest marvel
videos for live updates and stupid memes
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof